hey Jim hey what's up hey
um I know it's last minute but I was
wondering what
[Music]
hey hey
um I know it's last minute but I was
wondering if it would be no that was you
I was wondering if it would be cool
I didn't do anything
I was wondering if it would be cool if
my problem oh my God wait
it's casual so I'm not really worried
about numbers or anything cool cool all
right thanks knock it off I'm connecting
this inner no that's not what you said
when I came in here you said that I was
conducting the interview now exactly how
much pot did you smoke
I want it on my desk by the end of the
day or you will receive a full
decidulation
what's that
[Laughter]
we had a funeral for a bird
I'm pretty sure none of that's real
you're not real
huh
Crews and Katie Holmes we had a baby and
they named it Shiloh and Brad Pitt and
Angelina they had a baby too and they
named it Surrey
I think I have those mixed up
oh my God
Jimbo last chance at carpool
you know what carpool
carpool yep a little carpool together
we're getting this separately several
Club left
a little carpool together
no
carpool
carpool together
I'll meet you there
I'm sorry we only take MasterCard or
Diners Club
come on come on here we go
what are you doing here
you want to go today I can't give him
blood so
good for you good for you
how often can you actually donate blood
is there a limit I don't I thought there
was well
your body only has a certain amount
[Laughter]
I guess what surround sound means is
that right over here Tim
[Laughter]
figures
two speakers
what honey oh Jesus this is terrible
never finish this episode
um check this out
Falls
sorry oh my God
hmm
[Laughter]
I'm sorry we just wanted to say we're
very sorry screw you guys are dead to me
if you say screw you one more time
okay guys
face you like if you say screw you one
more time guys cool
it makes no sense if you say screw you
one more time hey guys just cool it
you knew you knew that what was that
basically the Dynamics of
all right basically in the workplace
[Laughter]
oh
there's always a theme idiot idiot
okay well you clearly don't care so why
don't you just leave I would like to
stay this pertains to me I would like
you to leave why don't you go outside
and take a shot of insulin and have a
nap okay why do you always assume I have
diabetes you have a glass of apple juice
and tell me that you don't have diabetes
okay
see just the noise you made when you
stood up I could
the more we expose ourselves to germs
the stronger
don't make me pre-fire you you wouldn't
dare
oh man and when I get promoted you're
full-fired if you get promoted ah
don't make me pre-fire you you wouldn't
dare you're pre-fired and when I'm
promoted you're full fired if you're
promoted
oh it's just like the old days I still
want to quit
but if I quit we'll all quit it'll be
Anarchy
[Music]
I still want to quit
but if I quit
we'll all quit
foreign
I so want to quit
but if I quit we'll all quit it'll
does this even work the mall is corrupt
Molly's evil their appearances okay
right
Jim that is so inappropriate
we actually love musical theater
Lincoln the last one
we actually love musical theater the
great thing about Stephen um
learning every
refrigerator is his father
is that what happened to you I'll tell
you what happened to me
tell you what happened to me I didn't
see my father for the first two years of
his life
of his life
oh look on your face was so funny I mean
I I'm feeling that it's it's very full
so I don't think she's been releasing at
all you're definitely feeling that
the baby should grab onto that I think
she will she'll be good so like a c
ertain just grab onto it and I squeeze
it that hard yeah yeah that hard yeah I
really feel it it's getting repetitive I
think we got it
hey out of curiosity do you have any
other characters oh I'm working on
Scranton Strangler
um
what do you think
oh I'm working on a new one it's Grand
Strangler
oh I'm working on the Scranton Strangler
don't start laughing I'm working
I'm working on a new one strand
Strangler
not laughing okay you know what Jim I am
taking you off this account for
unrelated read don't you smirk at me
okay
okay you know what Jim get your tongue
in your face
who is it
is it who is it Michael
you say hi
hi
you have to have sex with a woman then
sex with a man and then just compare the
two
um preferably been the same night
would you consider nope taking that
bullet for me
foreign
and then just compare when you think
about both
when are you free
sorry
[Laughter]
what happened to foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign